[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend den
Sport an diesem zweiten
Weihnachtsfeiertag hat Rudi zerne für
Sie sehr gerne schönen guten Abend und
wir schauen in dieser Sendung unter
anderem auf die
Überschwemmungen Böden und Dämme
durchweicht Talsperren voll in vielen
Teilen Deutschlands bleibt die
Hochwasserlage
kritisch Schlag gegen Russlands
Schwarzmeerflotte bei einem ukrainischen
Luftangriff auf die Krim wird ein großes
Landungsschiff
getroffen und wie teuer wird der Sprit
im neuen Jahr Sozialverbände sind über
die Belastungen durch die höhere CO2
Abgabe besorgt Umweltschützern reichen
die Maßnahmen
nicht der tagelange Dauerregen sorgt an
vielen Orten in Deutschland für
Hochwasser bundesinnenministerin Feser
dankte den Einsatz kräften die die
ganzen Weihnachtstage über im Einsatz
waren Überschwemmungen drohen vor allem
an vollgelaufenen stauseehen in
SachsenAnhalt wurden am Abend die 180
Menschen der Ortschaft türungen
aufgefordert ihre Häuser zu verlassen
über die aktuelle Lage in Deutschland
Christian
Volk sie ist randvoll die ckertalsperre
im Harz offizieller Füllstand laut
Betreiber
102%. so etwas gab es seit fast 30
Jahren nicht mehr deshalb ist nun der
Überlauf geöffnet worden tausende Liter
Wasser pro Sekunde strömen zusätzlich in
den Fluss wir hoffen jetzt auf
eine gewisse Beruhigung die wird auch
notwendig sein aber die Wetterprognose
die wird für uns in den nächsten Tagen
immer die Nachricht sein die uns am
allermeisten interessiert wegen der
Wassermassen gilt für Städte unterhalb
der Sperre Überschwemmungsgefahr
Braunschweig etwa wird das Wasser in
wenigen Stunden erreichen diese Gefahr
ist für die Bewohner von rinel längst
Realität am frühen Morgen mussten die
Einsatzkräfte ausrücken und mehr als 100
Menschen in Sicherheit bringen kein
Weihnachten ne habe Angst dass mir die
Bude das mir alles weg
wegschwimmt ich kann nicht bleiben ich
ist ja
gefährlich der kleine Ort Windehausen
ist bereits seit gestern weitestgehend
evakuiert von den 500 Einwohnern sind
noch etwa 100 geblieben seit dem
Nachmittag gilt ein Betretungsverbot wer
noch da ist schaut sich die Schäden an
schaut was noch zu retten ist die beiden
Autos sind unter Wasser mein Audi steht
in der Garage da sieht's noch gut aus
ist auf jeden Fall nichts
reingelaufen ja unten das Wasser ist
jetzt raus aus dem Haus schon auf jeden
Fall aber sieht e schie aus ne im
Landkreis Leer gelang es der Feuerwehr
zwei Dammbrüche zu verhindern dort geht
das Wasser zurück auch der deutsche
Wetterdienst hat seine Warnungen
aufgehoben an einigen Flüssen bleibe die
Situation aber
angespannt auch bei unseren Nachbarn im
Westen und Osten hat es viel geregnet in
Tschechien stehen in einigen Gegenden
Straßen und Gärten unter Wasser in der
Hauptstadt Prag wurden schon gestern
Fluttore an der Moldau geschlossen im
niederländischen deventar wo die Eisel
über die Ufer getreten ist nimmt man es
noch gelassen doch auch hier beobachten
Sie die Pegel und Deiche ganz
genau in der Ukraine sind es nun schon
die zweiten Weihnachten in Kriegszeiten
wegen der weiter heftigen Kämpfe will
die ukrainische Regierung den Einzug von
Soldaten für die Front erleichtern dazu
wurden dem Parlament zwei neue Gesetze
vorgelegt auf der Krim haben die
Luftstreitkräfte ein russisches
Kriegsschiff angegriffen mehr dazu von
Alissa
jung zielgenau greift die Ukraine den
Hafen von feodosia auf der von Russland
besetzten Halbinsel
und trifft das russische Landungsschiff
noask Russland spricht von Schäden die
Ukraine von einem
Kuh da ist uns etwas Großes gelungen ein
großes Landungsschiff wurde getroffen
und wurde Teil der Flotte zerstörter
Schiffe wozu schon die Moskwa
gehört diese hatte die Ukraine zu Beginn
des Krieges versenkt Panzer Drohnen
Munition konnte die nobask
transportieren hier ein Erfolg für die
Ukrainer doch im Verlust Russland
verkündet die Eroberung der Kleinstadt
marianka der Krieg hört an Weihnachten
nicht einfach auf in den Wohnungen
feiern viele Frauen Schwester Töchter
ohne die Männer so auch Familie Petrova
in pokrowsk der Vater kämpft an der
Front als ich den Weihnachtsbaum
geschmückt habe erinnerte ich mich daran
wie es früher war als alle zu Hause
waren als Papa da war das war früher
aber jetzt ist alles nur noch eine
Erinnerung an hellere Tage gemin
als Geschenk hat der Vater einen
Obstkorb geschickt um zu zeigen dass er
an sie denkt doch das größte Geschenk
war sein freier Tag vor ein paar
Wochen als er neulich da war hatte es
sich mehr wie Weihnachten angefühlt weil
alle zu Hause
waren sie wollen stark sein fürreinander
die Töchter für die Mutter und die
Mutter für ihre Mädchen und den
Mann ich versuche die Kinder nicht
anzuschreien und Ihnen meine Gefühle
nicht zu ze ich möchte sie schützen
damit Sie den Stress nicht
spüren ihr größter Wunsch für nächstes
Jahr wieder zu vit zusamm
sein die Bundesregierung hat vor kurzem
beschlossen eine kampfbrigade der
Bundeswehr in Litauen zu stationieren
jetzt warnt hereresinspekteur Mais vor
den Folgen ohne milliardenschwere
Investitionen drohe eine Schwächung der
Truppen in Deutschland das berichtet der
Spiegel und beruft sich auf ein internes
Schreiben danach ist laut Mais ist die
Ausstattung des Heeres gemessen an
seinen Aufträgen ab
2025 mehr als
grenzwertig Israel ist erneut vom
Libanon aus mit Raketen beschossen
worden die israelische Armee hat nach
eigenen Angaben zurückgeschossen im
Gazastreifen wird die Lage für die
Zivilbevölkerung unterdessen immer
aussichtsloser es gebe dort keinen
sicheren Ort mehr so die Vereinen
Nationen Henriette Deia
berichtet ein weiterer Tag in diesem
Krieg mit Tod Elend und Verwüstung nach
einem Raketenangriff der israelischen
armeeen Raffa sind die Menschen
Zivilisten die aus dem Norden hierher
geflüchtet sind
verzweifelt niemand von den arabischen
Ländern hilft uns die politischen Führer
sie sind das Problem nicht das Volk die
Leute sind gut aber die Führer sind das
Problem nur 5 km entfernt den Chis
beklagen Menschen ihre tote nach
Beschuss der iselischen Armee mehr als
20 000 Menschen im Gazastreifen sollen
nach Angaben der von der Hamas
kontrollierten Gesundheitsbehörde bisher
getötet worden sein Zivilisten und
Kämpfer der Hamas wenn die Israelis
wirklich Stärke hätten würden sie nicht
wehrlose Zivilisten angreifen
stattdessen sollten Sie sich den
Kämpfern Stellen nicht Menschen töten
die in ihren Häusern Zuflucht
[Musik]
suchen das israelische Militär
veröffentlichte heute Bilder von
Straßenkämpfen im
gaserreifens präsentierte den pund von
Kalaschnikow Gewehren Raketen und
Handgranaten versteckt in einem
Kinderzimmer es würden auch weiter
verschiedene strategische Methoden
angewendet so der Chef der israelischen
Armee heute abend dieser Krieg wird noch
für viele Monate weitergehen und wir
werden verschiedene Taktiken anwenden
damit wir dauerhafte Erfolge haben
werden es werde keine schnelle keine
zauberlösung dieses Krieges geben nun
schon 81 Tage
wert das US-Militär hat im Irak Angriffe
auf schiitische Milizen geflogen dabei
seien wahrscheinlich mehrere Kämpfer der
proiranischen Milizen getötet sowie
Gebäude zerstört worden teilte das
US-Militär mit die USA regierten damit
nach eigenen Angaben auf Drohnenangriffe
der Milizen auf mehrere us-stutzpunkte
im Irak drei Soldaten seinen verletzt
worden in Nigeria sind bei Angriffen auf
christliche Dörfer weit über 100
Menschen getötet worden hunderte weitere
wurden laut Behörden verletzt die
betroffenen Gemeinden machen muslimische
viehirden für die Angriffe
verantwortlich die liefern sich immer
wieder mit ansässigen Bauern Gefechte es
geht um Land und Zugang zu Wasser die
Klimakrise verschärft den
Konflikt Papst franziskus hat am zweiten
Weihnachtsfeiertag an die Schicksale
Verfolg der Christinnen und Christen
erinnert noch immer würden viele
Menschen wegen ihr Glaubens Leiden und
Sterben sagte er am Mittag auf dem
Petersplatz nach dem Angelus Gebet rief
franziskus erneut dazu auf für Frieden
in der Welt zu beten und zu
kämpfen nach einem Wohnhaus Brand in
Wächtersbach in Hessen ermitteln
Staatsanwaltschaft und Staatsschutz der
Verdacht eine rassistisch motivierte
Brandstiftung es seien mehrere
rassistische Schmierereien gefunden
worden das Feuer war in der Nacht zum
Montag ausgebrochen in dem lebte eine
aus Pakistan stammende Familie sie hatte
sich zum Zeitpunkt des Brandes nicht im
Gebäude aufgehalten verletzt wurde
niemand klimafreundliche Technologien
fördern das ist das Ziel der
Bundesregierung und die CO2 Abgabe ist
eines der Mittel zum 1 januar steigt sie
von derzeit 30 auf 45 € pro Tonne
Kohlendioxid so sollen fossile
Brennstoffe unattraktiver werden das
heißt vor allem tanken und heizen wird
teurer Markus Aust hat die
Details einmal volltanken bitte für
viele bereits jetzt eine finanzielle
Herausforderung und die CO2 Abgabe macht
tanken demnächst noch teurer durch die
Erhöhung der CO2 Abgabe wird der Liter
Benzin im kommenden Jahr 4,3 Cent mehr
Kosten der Liter Diesel 4,8 Cent
Unverständnis an der
Zapfsäule geht einfach nicht wie sollen
die Leute das mittlerweile bezahlen ich
find das ganz beschissen auch mit Öl
oder Gas wird teurer eine
durchschnittliche Familie mit zwei
Kindern muss 2024 fürs Heizen und tanken
114 € mehr ein Plan zu wenig um
großflächig Lenkungseffekte zu erzielen
sagen
Wirtschaftsexperten das alleine wird
jetzt nicht viele Menschen dazu bringen
den Verbrenner das Auto stehen zu lassen
oder sich ein Elektrofahrzeug zu kaufen
das sehen auch Umweltschützer so und
fordern der CO2 Preis muss noch
schneller steigen angesichts der
gigantischen umweltfolgekosten durch die
CO2 Emissionen ist der eh viel zu
niedrig steigende CO2 Abgaben nur wenn
parallel entlastet wird so die
Sozialverbände deswegen braucht jetzt
wirklich Maßnahmen um insbesondere
Menschen die eben zu geringen Löhnen
arbeiten die z.B nur den Mindestlohn
verdienen jetzt gut zu unterstützen und
da fordere ich die Bundesregierung
wirklich auf jetzt ganz zügig in soziale
ausgewogenes klimageld einzuführen das
kommt wenn überhaupt wohl erst
2025 dann wird die CO2 Abgabe weiter
steigen der Spitzensport macht auch an
Weihnachten keine Pause nee sag uns W
heute ran musst du die Basketballer z.B
in der Bundesliga der 13 Spieltag und
die neiners Chemnitz sind da weiterhin
nicht zu stoppen der Spitzenreiter der
Liga setzte sich deutlich gegen Tabellen
Schlusslicht kreilshheim mit 95 Z 67
durch zu den besten Akteuren gehörte
Kevin jebo für Kemnitz war es der Z Liga
siegt
nacheinander das überfliegerteam der
Basketball Bundesliga kommt gut erholt
aus der Weihnachtspause jebo mit dem 21
Z 155 für kemlitz kreilzheim hält
zunächst prima mit Stucky mit dem Dreier
und kurz danach Oduro zur
2221 Führung für den
Tabellenletzten im zweiten Viertel zieht
Kemnitz davon Fastbreak kajam keen
erstmals 10 Punkte vor die erst 3 Jahre
in der BBL mit deutlich geringerem ETA
als die ligagrößen danach souverän Kevin
jebo heute mit 20 Punkten der Topscorer
am Ende 95 z67 für Kemnitz im 13
Ligaspiel der 12te Sieg Silvester geht
zum Spitzenspiel nach
Berlin und nach nur zwei Tag
Weihnachtspause haben sich die Eisbären
Berlin mit einem 21 Sieg gegen die
Grizzlys Wolfsburg zurückgemeldet durch
den Erfolg am zweiten Feiertag bleibt
der deutsche Rekord sportmeister den
Tabellenführern aus Bremerhafen mit nur
einem Punkt Rückstand auf den Fersen
Eishockey Action statt Besinnlichkeit an
Weihnachten für die Fans von
Tabellenführer Berlin ein Pflichttermin
die Eisbären tun sich aber lange schwer
mit der Verteidigung der grizzliys aus
Wolfsburg erst im zweiten Drittel Platz
der Knoten Tobias Eder trifft zum 1:0
nach 29 Minuten ein Tor durch die Beine
von Keeper das den strahlmeier direkt
danach aber die kalte Dusche Berlin
verliert den Puck Bordin Schuss kann H
Brand noch abwehren Garret Fauser aber
setzt aus kurzer Distanz nach Ausgleich
für die grizzliys fausers erster
Saisontreffer ein shoränder auch die
Entscheidung fällt im zweiten Drittel
Marcel nöbels schöner Pass auf Jaden des
Chau 2:1 die Eisbären bescheren ihren
Fans einen knappen Sieg gegen
Wolfsburg kurzer Sport heute morgen
biete ich dir meh sehr gut danke Rudi
2023 geht langsam zu Ende und wie immer
schauen wir da auf die Ereignisse zurück
die das Jahr geprägt haben gleich nacher
uns im Album 2023 Bilder eines Jahres
unter anderem mit diesem sportlichen
Höhepunkt Deutschlands Basketballer im
Goldrausch der Traum vom
Weltmeistertitel wird wahr und das zum
ersten Mal in der Geschichte eine
sensationelle Leistung erreicht durch
echten
[Applaus]
Teamgeist und wir haben noch die
Wetteraussichten für morgen im
Nordwesten regnet es zeitweise sonst ist
es freundlicher und trocken ganz im
Süden auch sonnig am Bodensee hält sich
am Vormittag Nebel die Höchstwerte
liegen zwischen 5 und
12° die kommenden Tage bringen vor allem
im Norden und Westen etwas Regen dabei
bleibt es mild die nächsten Nachrichten
sehen Sie bei uns gegen 23:15 Uhr auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen
ه